for every year that people remain
healthy every additional year it's worth
$38 billion the global economy which is
massive you know I have two 12-year-old
boys I had at 50 I'm looking forward to
seeing them when when they turn 50 and
I'm 100 I'm excited to see humans
Walking on Mars starting colonies on the
moon I love life and I want to live as
much of it as I possibly can you know we
are going to make cancer heart disease
neurogenerative disease a thing of the
past all right guys bang bang I've got
Peter here uh Peter you are the founder
of X prize is probably one of the
coolest projects in my opinion uh you
guys put a big big dollar amount out
there and you say anyone in the world
regardless of who you are where you come
from what your background is if you can
solve this problem you get this prize
and it used to be you know million
dollars $10 million now you're launching
hundred million x prizes why is it so
important to have a prize that people
really driving towards to continue to
drive Innovation and
ambition thanks buddy it's good to see
you um you know I there's a saying I
love uh that without a Target you'll
miss it every time um we are as a
species uh extraordinarily good in uh in
competition right we do our best work
when we're competing in the Olympics or
in business why not do that as well in
solving the world's biggest problems and
so what we when we run these
competitions we put a Target um we say
like you said I don't care where you
went to school what you've ever done if
you solve this problem and this is what
you have to do and it and it aims
everybody in the same direction uh and
gives them uh a Target to shoot for uh
and a lot of times people are looking
for an excuse they're looking for a
reason to jump in um and and these X
prises incentivize people now here's
what's different today it used to be
that a 100 years ago the only people who
could make a difference on a big problem
were the Kings and the Queens the
industrialists the government um but now
uh you know a small team using AI using
uh you
know the technologies that are at our
fingertips can do something uh mirac
ulous and so we're looking at
crowdsource
Solutions and and so that's what we're
doing we're saying what are the world's
biggest problems how do we target people
to solve them um and we create a Level
Playing Field where a small brilliant
you know team can compete against the
big one there's one other important
point I should make here that it's a
saying I love which is the day before
something is a breakthrough it's a crazy
idea right if it weren't a breakthrough
if weren't a crazy idea it would be an
expect
Improvement but if it truly is a crazy
idea and where inside organizations do
you try crazy ideas um large companies
are fearful of failure governments don't
want Congressional investigations and so
it becomes the young team that is
willing to try a crazy idea and fail
over and over and over again now the
latest X prise is around longevity uh or
increasing Health spend I think maybe a
great way to think about this is like
people always want to be healthy for the
most part uh but there's two ways that
you can think about this you can think
about it as I want to live to 150 and so
that literally extending life or you
could think about it as improving the
quality of the years that you have and I
think the holy Grill is to do both to
have more years and also have a higher
quality of the years how are you
thinking about longevity today and why
do we need the X prize to really drive
forward some of these breakthroughs and
Longevity great question so you know
lifespan is how long your heart's taking
Health span is how long do you feel
vibrant energetic uh live um you know
it's interesting I was about five six
years ago was on the stage of the
Vatican uh at a medical conference and
in the room was you know uh Cardinals
and Priests and Physicians and
scientists you know it was it was a
crazy audience and I was speaking about
the morality of
immortality and
uh I asked an innocent question to the
room 500 people in the room there right
all at the invitation of the Pope and I
said how many of you want to live to 120
years old and I expected everyone's
hands to go up and like 20% of the room
raised their hands and I'm like what the
what's up and the problem is that we
have a mental image of 120 as being
slobbering in a wheelchair
disabled and that historically is true
and so no one wants that
um and so we need to change that so
lifespan and health span is living 2 120
in a vibrant way that you're enjoying
life you're hanging out with your great
great grandchildren and you're
cognitively physically there so um this
ex prise you know we've done well in
lifespan we doubled over the last
century from 40 to 80 years old
roughly but that's lifespan Health span
still lags by 10 years so
um this prize we've launched um to get
into the specifics it's a it's 101
million
purse and um it's 101 million because
the friend of mine chip Wilson the
founder of Lululemon who put up the
first roughly $30
million uh wanted it to be bigger than
the prize we had with Elon Musk which
was $100 million for carbon removal and
so um
uh funny enough we ended up uh making
101 then he added then chip added
another $10 million of bonus money for
his particular disease which is a
muscular distrophy called fshd that's
111 million of prize money and to win
this prize uh a team needs to
demonstrate that they have a therapy
that with given for up to a year could
reverse your cognitive your uh muscular
and immune age by 20 years right so that
uh and this is going to be done in
patients and me in subjects age 65 and
older so we need to show that you have
the uh you know as we grow older we
start to lose function across everything
our cognitive function our muscular our
strength and ability to build muscle our
ability to mount an immune defense
against a challenge of some type what if
you could turn back the clock 10 years
or 20 years on those three things that's
what this challenge is about uh we
announced it in actually Saudi Arabia
it's funded by a foundation called
Evolution which is out of the out of s
out of Riyad and and the US and with
chip Wilson and a number of benefactors
including myself we have over 200 teams
entered so far I expect we'll get close
to
1,000 uh and this competition will run
through 2000 and
30 uh and I hope it will Source amazing
new
approaches uh to maintain our and uh
maintain our health a decade or two
longer as the goal when we see people
talking about longevity today I think
there are the Davidson Claire's hey
we're in a lab and we're doing uh what
most people consider kind of academic
research to try to find uh maybe things
we can take or food we should eat or or
various uh protocols that we should
follow then you can go and you can look
at someone like O'Brien Johnson who you
know is doing everything from getting
peptide uh injections all the way to
literally I think he recently announced
he got Botox injected into uh his male
genitalia and you know trying to figure
out how does that have an impact um
there's obviously the you know uh use of
young people's blood that whether it's
venture capitalist to you know many
others over the years have been rumored
to to do and so there's all these kind
of again crazy ideas or wacky ideas when
you evaluate the space today like what
are the things that are working right
like when you say hey I'm talking to a
friend they say I want to live longer
life are there things that maybe are
like free and then there's things that
the average person could afford that
they could do yeah for sure um let me
frame it as following there's an idea
called Longevity escape
velocity and that concept put forward by
AUB deg gry and Ray Kur I love it
because when when people say how long
you want to live Peter I used to give
some ridiculous multi- hundred-year
answer um ridiculous only because if you
hit longevity escape velocity you can
live as long as you desire so what does
that mean today for every year that
you're alive science is extending your
year your life for a quarter to a third
of a year right there are breakthroughs
every year that are making you healthier
and living longer there is a moment in
time where that for every year that
you're alive science extending your life
for more than a
year right and that concept is called
Longevity Escape philosophy and say you
know it it it's a departure and and um
so the question is when will we reach
this idea of longevity escape philosop
and uh I interviewed a number of
individuals Ray Kur George Church David
Sinclair and the belief is that it is in
the neighborhood of 15 years
out maybe 20 years out at most uh as a
result of AI and Quantum Technologies
and maybe sooner and so um what you
really want to do is how do you maintain
your health for the next 10 years the
next 20 years you don't want to be the
last person to arrive you know to the
day before lunch escape velocity so um
what do you do now and I ended up
writing this book uh longevity practical
Playbook outlining everything I do and
why um and it falls into a number of of
categories um the first is the basics
that are free right and uh it
is first and foremost exercise um I hate
to say it people don't like to do it I
do I work out at least with weights four
days a week and I I'm on a uh techno gym
bike for three or four days a week um uh
getting my my zone 2 training but it's
adding muscle mass I added 10 pounds of
muscle last year uh aggressively to get
there because there's a direct
correlation between muscle and
Longevity um and there are things you
can do to maintain and grow your muscle
mass uh it gets harder as you get older
and you have to work harder for it but
it is definitely worth it exercising
just once or twice a week reduces your
chance of all cause mortality by 50%
reduces chance of cancer by three-fold
it's a big deal if exercise could be
bottled in the pill it would be a
trillion dollar medical miracle right um
so people know it just got to do it um
and frankly any amount of exercise is
better than being a couch potato and
sitting down uh the second thing is diet
and um and there's no one diet for
everybody but there are a few things
that are true and hate to say it but
sugar is a poison the body never evolved
to eat as much sugar as we do it's a
inflammatory um Factor uh uh
cardiovascular and neuroinflammatory it
is just it's bad uh and so it's
addictive and so minimizing high
glycemic index foods and and sugar and
breaking that sugar addiction is one of
the most important things maximizing um
uh vegetables uh colored vegetables um I
me sleep eight hours of sleep
fundamental the body could have evolved
away it didn't eight you know sleep is
part I used to like in medical school I
would be so proud when i' do like I can
do this in four and a half or five hours
of sleep right um mindset is incredibly
important um there's a great study I
quote in the book uh of
69,7 44 Women and 1429 guys and it was
done by the National Academy of Sciences
or published in National science
proceedings and optimists lived 15%
longer than pessimists amazing um and
then uh the final thing for me um you
know I talk about the meds and
supplements and I'm on rrap ayin and I
take berberine instead of metformin and
I don't want to go into that because
everybody's different but I outline
everything I do and I say see your
doctor but the last thing that I think
is so important and is not dying from
something stupid you know if I were to
ask you pomp you know do you know what's
going on inside your body right now are
you sure that there's nothing going on
inside your body to worry about how do
you answer it no of course not you want
to think you want to think that you do
but you 100% don't and I'll even give
you a step further um I have friends who
say hey I go see a doctor you know every
six months and I try to stay on top of
what the the recommended thing is um you
know my wife and I had uh our second
child and we went to go see the
doctor the day before the baby was born
and she said oh you guys have at least
two more weeks before the baby's going
to be born and 12 15 hours later she
shows up to uh the hospital and realizes
that we're there and she's like I wasn't
expecting to see you for two weeks well
we're like you know hey you're the
doctor right aren't you supposed to know
you know two weeks to you know 12 hours
later that's pretty big difference and
part of it is even if you have the
medical professional it's really hard
right that the human body is so unique
and and things can get missed or
misinterpreted as well this episode is
brought to you by frck historically the
wealthy had a hidden secret in investing
they would spend a lot of money and use
very big teams to conduct tax loss
harvesting tax loss harvesting is the
timely selling of Securities at a loss
to offset the amount of capital gains
tax owed from selling the profitable
assets later but now frck is bringing
this incredible advantage to any
investor they'll literally lower your
tax bill regardless of how how much
money you have they use state-of-the-art
technology through a product called
direct indexing to allow investors to
invest in the S&P 500 while getting all
the benefits of tax loss harvesting
without the big Bill if you want to
learn more go check them out at fre.com
that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business fre.com go check them out today
so yeah 100% so we know more about
what's going on inside our car or
refrigerator than we do our body and
that's a problem let me give you some of
the facts so first of all you have to
realize that the body is incredibly good
at hiding
disease the body
compensates um which is amazing right so
you don't feel cancer at stage one or
stage two only when it reaches stage
three or stage four do you feel
something at which point sometimes you
know it's too
late uh you don't feel an aneurysm
that's
developing um
70% of all heart
attacks have
no precedent no shortness of breath no
pain no
anything
and half of the heart attacks end up in
death so it's like boom like we we've
all had friends I had a fraternal
brother of mine who was going to go down
to Fountain life a month he had made an
appointment month out he died in
asleep um another friend of mine went
through Fountain life um in our Orlando
facility uh because we were going to do
business together I said go through it
experience it you know and we found two
brain aneurysms he was in surgery a week
later and then back at work a week after
that so in our first 5,000 members who
go through what Fountain life is it's a
full body upload it's everything
knowable about your body that's knowable
um It's You Know full body MRI brain
brain vasculature an AI enabled coronary
CT looking for soft plaque dexas scan
full genome metabolome microbiome 120
blood
biomarkers
everything and out of the first 5,000
members 2% two out of 100 people have a
cancer they don't know
about uh 2 and a half% have an aneurysm
they don't know about
14.4% have a significant life-saving
finding metabolic disease cardiovascular
disease neur degenerative disease cancer
out um
aneurysms and
so you know listen the body was never
evolved to live past age 30 um and it's
downhill from there and so stuff starts
going on you just don't know about it
and so people say I don't want to know I
like of course you want to know
well you're going to find out you want
to find out about now or when it's too
late so I write about that in this book
on the chapter of I called don't die
from something stupid and I think not
looking is is kind of silly
um so you know sleep diet exercise
understand what's going inside your body
and then there's a whole slew of new
Therapeutics coming out and this health
span X prise is going to drive a lot of
those breakthroughs as well what what
about um I'm going to call it consumer
wearables as kind of a category you know
if I think of my own personal life uh
the Apple watch it's not the most
stylish watch actually some people would
say hey why you wearing that stupid
watch
but I notice that it tells me how many
steps I take or you know did I close my
rings in terms of exercise and uh for
whatever reason it makes me want to make
sure that I close the Rings and so it
has this like great feedback loop I know
people who wear the aura ring or they
sleep on an eight Sleep mattress or you
know name your device and it feels like
maybe the tech sector uh and where it
intersects with health is driving better
behaviors to some degree and then on the
other hand you know you also have people
who just sit at their desk all day and
doom scroll on their favorite social
media app and maybe that's actually
contributing to a negative side effect
so how do you kind of think about tech
um you know and its Evolution here yeah
I have a uh an appendix at the back of
this book that
lists all the stuff available and the
stuff that I use and by the way you can
get uh a free digest it's not the full
book it's it's a summary of 30 page
summary of all the book and includes
that list uh if someone goes to DM
andis.com longevity you can get it I
just want to get this information out
there um I wear I'm always wearing
continuous glucose monitor right uh
either by levels or by freely bra and
monitoring my glucose levels not because
I don't I just want to be it keeps me
cognizant of what I'm eating right I
don't want to eat something and watch it
Spike um I wear my aura ring not because
it puts me to sleep but because it
reminds me in the morning um to that I'm
going to be looking to get a sleep score
above 90 right I use my I have an eight
sleep mattress a well I've got my my
actually is charging my Apple watch um
my Venture fund bold Capital uh about
two-thirds of our investments are in
biotech and there's a whole slew of new
wearables so one of the places that
Fountain life is going um we have these
centers we're building out
uh centers around the world uh but the
ultimate goal is fountain at home where
you're
wearables and as a fountain member you
get a number of wearables integrated
into our digital app that your physician
is watching with you for
you um ultimately all of these wearables
are uh also in your room in your
mattress of your bed and your chair
listening to your typing your voice the
what your cough is like and all of this
data is going to your AI which is your
ultimate
diagnostician and it's you know catching
things even earlier so Health monitoring
will be 247 eventually if you want it to
be you can turn it on or turn it
off when you see um that Health
monitoring how much of it is uh
personalized Foods right in the things
that you know lab grown meats and and
we're starting to see Innovation where I
think people are saying okay today it
looks just like can we change the cost
structure maybe there's a animal and
Humanity you know uh type of approach to
this but is it really that far off from
us to say okay I'm monitoring my glucose
and these other markers on a continuous
basis uh I'm not getting enough of a
certain you know vitamin mineral protein
whatever and so therefore I'm going to
start to cater my diet but not just
order from a certain place or cook a
certain food I'm actually going to have
the food
specially made in a personalized way to
my exact needs or is that a little bit
too sci-fi no no no not at all um uh I
think that is definitively coming uh
we've talked about that specifically at
Fountain life um as
a an
adjacency with our our residential
Partners but so for example I don't eat
gluten I don't eat dairy um I don't E I
don't eat gluten because that's what my
lab results tell me right um and if
you're being monitored
24/7 by what's going on your vitamin
levels your hormone levels your all of
that it is possible for your AI to know
exactly what foods you should or should
not eat and uh to be transmitting that
to the to the right agents that are
producing your Foods so I do think in
the final result result and I don't
think it's you know more than two to
five years max out um but your your
health biomarkers will determine the
food you end up eating um in a in an
automatical way um if you want to turn
that function on
when I think of the furthest out of all
of this um recently there was an
announcement around the enhanced games
which is the olyp
but uh you basically can take whatever
steroids do whatever you want love the
idea by the way I do love it and I know
the team buil uh who's proposed it yes
and is that where kind of sports culture
Society in general like should we expect
to have a leaner fitter you know uh
Society of people because the science
gets infused uh in a way or um things
like maybe OIC where yeah it can help
you lose weight but there's concerns
around you know muscle mass or bone
density and kind of some of the the
downsides like how do you think about
just like the augmentation of humans
both for culture and Society but also
for sport like in the enhanced games
yeah you know it used to be that where
we were born what gender we're born into
what religion we born into uh all of
that determined the rest of our life
forever your C the cast system and so
forth today that is no longer the case
you can
you can reinvent
yourself uh I think that the most
interesting
reinvention is going to be coming from
crisper and Gene therapies right so for
example um to take
it slightly different
direction uh there are 130 trials going
on right now for chrisper treatments so
again we learned how to sequence the
human
genome the price went from 3 billion to
100 million it's down to 200 bucks now
for your genome the third the the 3
billion letters from your mom and your
dad and your genome your software um you
know determines a lot not everything you
know it turns out that your genome only
is responsible for at maximum 20% of
your
longevity lifestyle changes are are the
vast
majority but if you have a genetic
disease uh genetic uh uh blindness uh
hearing loss um uh CLE cell anemia beta
Thalia a whole slew of of diseases
because a particular nucleotide in your
3.2 billion letters is off you can now
use crisper right two amazing women will
win the Nobel Prize in chemistry for
crisper in 2020 the ability to go in and
and edit your genome in your body and
that's biblical right right so you can
now go and edit yourself uh there are
other Gene hacks which will allow you to
uh eventually build more muscle um or uh
be able to you know uh change the color
of your skin or your hair or I mean
there's all kinds of things that are
coming and and and designer you know
designer uh babies may be a thing in the
future so there are lots of different
directions that we're going to go uh and
Society the problem is that Society is
ill prepared to deal with these things
at the speed at which they're developing
yeah the enhanced games is is cool and I
sure I'd love to see you know what what
the long jump looks like for someone
who's been you know hacked in a in a way
I mean it's more out of morbid curiosity
than anything else uh I I think the
Olympics will always be the gold
standard but I think just like we went
from
you know wrestling to uh what's it
called when you're when you're in a in
like cage like cage fights where you can
do anything you want right you know it's
like people like the extreme um but it's
also nice to know what you know what the
unaltered natural human can do but
there's a place for both now you said
the society is
ill-prepared why are they ill prepared
or what could we do to become more
rapidly prepared human beings don't like
change
fundamentally we like waking up in the
morning and knowing that the world is
the same world we went to sleep
in uh we have institutions governments
religious institutions and such which
are stabilizing
forces um I learned long ago that people
to a large degree Fear the Future
because they don't understand it and the
faster things are
moving um the more more concerned they
get
because they
are they understand the game they're
playing and you know I just gave a talk
to a middle school out here uh in in LA
to 150 teachers about where things are
going and rather than being excited I
think I scared the out of them um
which was concerning to me but
nonetheless it is what it is um
and the only constant is change and the
speed of change is increasing especially
with what we're seeing in in gener of AI
these days and humanoid robots that are
coming
um and so because the change is so fast
um and we deal with with the reaction
through culture through government laws
through institutions that don't change
don't like to change um
it's just going to be there is going to
be a departure diversion where we linear
humans are are constantly causing or
being disrupted or causing disruption on
institutions so we're seeing it it's
just going to continue to accelerate
when we see um the augmentation of
society and of the human I recently
tweeted and I said that there's an
increasing correlation between fake lips
fake news and fake money right and seems
like the society uh fake is a negative
connotation but you know there are some
benefits to some of these things um and
obviously huge detrimental uh impact to
to others how do you think about sifting
through some of these Evolutions as good
or bad you know fake lips is kind of
like well maybe it makes someone happy
also maybe it screws up their body maybe
doesn't neither one like how do you kind
of use as a framework to evaluate these
developments
yeah um we have to remember you know
listen I'm 62 years old uh I feel like
I'm my best shape ever and I'm working
hard on that it's important to me I
prioritize it second only to my kids
um but I'm I've gotten here and I'm in
the best shape I'm in because of all the
things I do in my own bioh hacks um
uh is it natural no natural is dead by
30 I mean just to remember right uh
100,000 years ago you would have a baby
at age 12 when you went into puberty
you'd be pregnant by 13 by the time you
were 26 27 28 you were a
grandparent and before we had McDonald's
and Whole Foods and food was
abundant uh your purpose was to
perpetuate the species pass on the genes
and you didn't want to compete against
your grandchildren for
food and society would have you die so
the body was never built to live past
age 30 just to be hyper clear for
anybody here over 30 you're on bar of
time buddy so uh it's but we enhance
that we solve these things we we create
antibiotics we pasteurize milk we get
better sanitation we we learn how to
catch disease early we learn which foods
do and do not injur us anyway um the
point being we're always modifying the
game um you know fake is a term we apply
like uh you know
uh was like I was on CNBC talking about
the uh Taylor Swift deep fakes um and
you know and Trump using you know
claiming deep fakes and all of that and
yeah those are issues uh when they're
negative we call them deep fakes when
they're positive things we call them
avatars we give them different names
right and digital avatars are extremely
valuable on a multitude of of ways for
education for business for sales for
marketing for bringing back loved ones
eventually so
um it's I don't know that it's anything
different than it's ever been it's just
a lot more moving a lot faster and our
institutions
uh are are evolving at the speed of
humans not at the speed of
AI when you see other technologies that
are pushing us forward um through
Innovation uh with have Bitcoin we've
artificial intelligence you know these
are things that you and I have talked
about uh before where do you see those
now is this something where everything
gets push forward together kind of in a
techno Optimist view of the world and
it's you know uh they all uh benefit if
AI gets pushed forward then these other
Technologies benefit uh or are they
somewhat siloed and progress on bitcoin
doesn't necessarily indicate progress on
you know longevity or or AI or something
like that this episode is brought to you
by bet online do you like making a
profit from sports betting well set
yourself up to take home the most profit
possible using crypto to fund your
sports betting casino and poker account
at bet
online.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdrawal limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at
betonline.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus if you use promo code pomp
100 bet online the game starts here
betonline.ag go check them out today I
think they're all moving in some Unison
for example um Bitcoin is predicated on
uh on blockchain and blockchain may be
the most important technology to prevent
uh deep fakes on the negative side right
having some mechanism of a
authentication in the metadata of a
image or a video that's on the
blockchain that allows you to verify it
and of course AI enables you to do the
research and do that better and
computational speed
and the ability for someone in the
middle of India using YouTube to educate
themselves uh and being able to
communicate with people in Thailand and
in California uh for free on you know on
WhatsApp I mean all these things are
just making the world faster and faster
the question ultimately is do you
believe that human nature is on the
whole good or bad if you believe on the
whole human nature is bad that all of
these Technologies as they become more
and more prevalent and available able
and cheaper and faster are going to be
used for nefarious purposes then we're
screwed um uh I happen to believe that
on the whole human nature is good and
that I Define an entrepreneur as someone
who finds a problem and solves a problem
and that the more entrepreneurs using
these Technologies to solve problems the
world is a better and healthier place
you know it used to be that the only
people who could solve
significant big problems on the planet
were the Kings and the Queens the robber
barons the industrialists you know very
small number of
individuals and even the best that they
could do was deploy their troops or
change monetary policies today a single
individual you know powered with the
world's knowledge on Google with with uh
you know gener of AI on on Gemini or or
or
gp4 can
can do something
extraordinary uh and so yes they can do
evil but I
just uh we're still here and we're still
fighting the good
fight we see uh rise of Robotics in
healthcare um we see the rise of AI
agents in software and it feels like uh
at some point someone's going to try to
put things like that together uh maybe
the like most absurd and advanced um
combination are the humanoid robots
where like just take the human
completely out of the out of the
equation and have a robot do everything
that the human can do happening now and
I I've been studying them right um uh
Tesla bot also known as Optimus uh out
of Tesla is amazing uh there's another
um another company called
Figure will disclosure I'm an invester
figure also doing humanoid robots and
then Amica out of engineer ered Arts out
of the UK an amazing emotive uh humanoid
robot right um this year at the
abundance Summit which I hold every
March uh we're going to spend two days
on AI we're calling it The Great AI
debate um and I'm going to be bringing
uh Mustafa saliman who is co-founder of
Deep Mind the CEO of inflection and and
Jeffrey Hinton and Ray kwell and Eric
Schmidt and moad do and we're going to
and uh Tristan and we're having a debate
about is AI positive is AI negative
where is it going how do you think about
it and ultimately how do you use it to
improve your business and make the world
a better place but just on the other
side of that are humanoid robots so um
we will we are seeing them now and you
know the prediction is millions by 2030
and billions by
2040 right and so elon's projection
projection and love
Elon uh trying to hold him to a schedule
and a price is tough uh but let's say
he's off by a factor of two and a and a
Optimist cost 40 or $50,000 instead of
20,000 bucks you know what Can you lease
a car for that costs 50k I don't know
400 bucks a month 500 bucks a month so
imagine having a fully capable Optimus
robot in your closet that while you're
at you know work is cutting the grass
cleaning the house preparing your meals
doing whatever you want that's pretty
amazing and that's
coming now when you see uh the rise of
that if you again go to the extreme of
what humans do uh Warfare is a huge uh
part of um I think where technology gets
tested gets innovated on and we have
seen uh the rise of drones uh the rise
of various uh weapon systems uh there
are now even in certain uh foxy wars
being fought globally drones with
explosives on them that are being flown
into things um again it's kind of like
you're mashing the Robotics and
Technology with what should be a human
but the progress is being accomplished
by just taking the human out of it and
going fullon Robotics and Tech and maybe
a human might control it remotely or or
you know be involved tangent but is
actually getting the humans out of the
way as a limiting factor for
progress yeah um listen there's no
question that Ai and Robotics of all
form is core in the 21st century defense
department I had uh pommer lucky the
fter of Oculus on my stage at abundance
Summit last year and he's the CEO of
andril um and andril is like one of the
most advanced high-tech defense
companies that people never heard of and
it's
crazy what he's been able to design but
it is an
AI architecture on top of physical
drones and subs and trucks and yeah
that's all concerning it's concerning
from
how how dehumanizing it is um I think uh
what Palmer would say is it would be
much more concerning if we didn't have
this ability uh Warfare for the longest
time has been very
inaccurate um and you would drop bombs
and hope you got the person and there
was lots of collateral and his vision is
what if your your bombs and your drones
and your robots are smart and they can
get the individual you want without the
collateral damage around
it um there is a Star Trek episode and I
love Gene rotenberry for all he explored
in in Star Trek I think it's called the
Forever War and there's just two
cultures that um got into a war and they
made it so neat and
clean um that that uh that the war you
know Wars are are are dirty and painful
and filled with catastrophes and and you
you want to stop them and because of the
ancel impact and in this episode the war
had become so neat and clean that people
it was run in a simulation and if your
if your home got bombed in a simulation
you'd walk into this chamber that would
kill you and it was so neat and clean
that the war continued for Millennia um
and it just went on and on and on and on
um and you know Captain Kirk shows up
and destroys this and says war is
supposed to be ugly and dirty so you
don't want to do it ever again
so I don't know um Ai and and humanoid
robotics in war you know uh it's coming
um and and you know is our our treaties
our
politicians uh smart enough to handle it
I don't know do you think that there
will be a day where the president of the
United States is AI or robotics or you
know some version of not the natural
human that we have today so I think that
there is going to be a day very soon
that every company is uh is basing its
leadership and its decisions on AI I
like to say by 2030 there are two kinds
of companies those that are fully
utilizing Ai and those that are out of
business right I'm super clear about
that uh there have as you know stunts to
some degree been AI board members and AI
CEOs installed you know when I have a
board meeting when I have a leadership
meeting for my my companies um I have
you know Bard or chat GPT open and I'm
asking it the same questions I'm asking
people or I might ask hey what would
Elon Musk think about this problem we're
having or what would Albert Einstein
think about this problem so one of the
problems we have as humans is we don't
know how to think other than the way we
know how to think but in using journey
of AI you can get different approaches
to your problem so it's where there in
part um I would hope that uh the
leadership at all levels of our nation
are going to be using generative AI uh
for uh their uh their future
decisions what is the thing that you are
most excited about when it comes to
longevity over the next 20 years right
we talked about technology we talked
about AI we talked about uh Bitcoin
robotics there's all this stuff that's
going on when it's in the longevity
field what is the thing that you're most
looking forward to I I think uh well
first of all getting the X prize one um
it's it's it's changing
people's vision of what 120 looks
like um there was a study done at
Harvard London School of Business Oxford
that said for
every year that people remain healthy
every additional year it's worth $38
billion to the global
economy um which is
massive and
so at the end of the
day um I want I think it's one of the
most important tipping points Society
can have um you know I have two
12-year-old boys I had at 50 you know um
I'm looking forward to seeing them when
when they turn 50 and I'm 100 you know
that is a a beautiful thing to think
about that I I think about you know my
heart as a child was always in space uh
I'm excited to see humans Walking on
Mars starting colonies on the moon I'm
excited to see the Fulfillment of the
science fiction future that will be 10
20 30 years out and I'm excited to
participate in that so all of that you
know I love life and I want to live as
much of it as I possibly can
um so I mean that that's the way I I
think about it
um you know we are going to make cancer
heart disease neurogenerative disease a
thing of the past it will be washed away
in the wake of these longevity
treatments we will learn how to
reprogram our
epigenomes right so I'll ask you a
question that uh ask people to ponder
this so you have three 3.2 billion
letters from your mom and 3.2 billion
letters from your dad uh you had it at
Birth you have the same exact software
you're running at 20 at 40 at 60 at 80
at 100 if you have the same software
running at 100 years old why don't you
look like you were when you're
20 right it's same
software well it's not what your what
genes you have it's what genes are on
and what genes are off it's your
epigenome the Greek word for above and
as we age what happens is the you know
the right genes get turned on but
sometimes they don't or sometimes the
genes supposed to be off are not off and
and that blurring of the lines
causes um causes aging to a large degree
and so some of the work done uh by David
Sinclair and George church and others
has said we should be able to control
our epigenome control what genes are on
or off and reverse take your
epigenetic um uh control system back to
a younger
state so that's longevity escape
velocity for sure so I'm looking forward
to that and I'm going to do everything I
can
um uh to you know including my uh my
breakfast that just got served up which
is some eggs and some uh olive oil and
some uh
avocado um which is staring at me over
here uh but I'll hold off uh you know I
do everything I can to
to uh to get there and part of it means
making choices not to have that bowl of
ice cream not to sit on your butt all
day where can we send people to uh to
get the book or learn more about the X
prise yeah so um the book if you want to
buy the hard cover uh it's on Amazon uh
just look up DM Andis and Longevity your
practical Playbook if you if you go to
demand.com
longevity um you can link to the book
there but you also get a a 30 page
digest which includes everything I'm I'm
doing and taking it's it's a dist
distillation of the book uh and I just
want to get the stuff out there um X
prise XPR i.org
um
uh is uh is where you can learn about
the X prize we have launched $500
million in prizes prizes to map the
ocean floor or pull water out of the
atmosphere uh we have a $100 million
prize for gigaton carbon removal that
Elon funded 6,000 teams entered that
competition and of course our $11
million Health span X prise going on now
uh so you know uh that's that's it I uh
uh if you're interested in in what I do
for coaching
CEOs uh abundance 360 is my CEO program
that I run uh year round it's part of
singular University and then Fountain
life we have saved hundreds of lives at
Fountain life um there's no better
investment honestly um anyway I'll leave
it at
that I um I'm inspired every time I talk
with you the future is going to be
absolutely insane and awesome at the
same time and uh we'll do this again in
the future to talk about uh some ofs
thank you for sharing um your time with
me uh grateful for you and you know it's
um it is the most extraordinary time
ever to be alive and I like to say you
know life is short until you extend it
so enjoy a pleasure pal